Cette nuit, c’est la pleine lune…
Mais pourquoi nous présente-t-elle
toujours la même face ?
C’est parce que la lune tourne sur elle-même,
un tour complet en un peu plus de 27 jours…
en même temps qu’elle fait le tour de la terre.
Si la lune restait fixe sur son axe,
quand elle se trouve dans cette position
on verrait sa face A et quand elle se trouve
dans cette position, sa face B.
Revenons à la case départ.
Etant donné que la lune tourne sur elle-même
au fur et à mesure qu’elle fait le tour de la terre,
quand elle a fait le quart du tour de notre planète,
elle a également fait un quart de tour sur elle-même
et présente la même face qu’au point de départ.
Un quart de tour supplémentaire
et elle a encore tourné sur elle-même…
et présente toujours la même face. Et ainsi de suite.
La lune présente toujours la même face
et ne montre jamais sa face cachée,
même à bord d’une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné"
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...